it's not as easy as you may think to
find a simple definition of the term
systemic racism given that we
hear it so often wielded with such
blithe certainty you'd be forgiven for
assuming that the phrase actually well
i don't know means something but it
takes some digging to discover what that
meaning
is if there is any meaning to discover
at all an article in usa today published
during the height of the blm riots last
summer
appears intent at first on answering the
question the headline says
what is systemic racism here's what it
means and how you can help dismantle it
okay simple enough the piece surveys
various civil rights leaders and
advocates including the head of the
naacp
and also the president of the racial
justice advocacy group race forward
between these authoritative sources the
following definitions
of systemic racism are offered and i'm
quoting now
the complex interaction of culture
policy institutions that holds in place
the outcomes we see in our lives also
systems and structures
that have procedures or processes that
disadvantage
african americans and also systemic
racism
is naming the process of white supremacy
okay so to summarize systems and
structures have procedures and policies
which interact with
cultures and institutions to create
outcomes which lead to disadvantages
caused by the process of white supremacy
well
that clears things up but the ambiguity
of course
is the point if systemic racism has no
clearly discernible definition
then the definition could be whatever
the activist needs it to be in any given
moment
systemic racism like so many other terms
these days sea
gender whiteness privilege human rights
etc
means anything and also everything and
also nothing all at the same time
but if you're not satisfied with the
fluidity of the term and you would like
to settle on something more solid so
that you can actually apply it to the
real world in a meaningful way
then perhaps this definition that i
found from the alberta
civil liberties research center will
suffice this is what they say
systemic racism includes the policies
and practices entrenched in established
institutions
which result in the exclusion or
promotion of designated groups
now this is still wordier and vaguer
than it needs to be and it seems to
dissemble a bit with the with the word
includes
you know but it gets us closer to the
answer all we really need is the last
part with a couple of additional
qualifiers
systemic racism if it means anything
must mean
the explicit and purposeful exclusion or
promotion of designated racial groups
by a powerful institution that's a
coherent and self-contained definition
which may render it useless to the
racial justice activists
but makes it useful to those of us who
are actually concerned about
finding and exposing true examples of
systemic racism in our society
and there are examples of it on that
note
here's an example that may be worth our
attention breitbart reports quote
restaurants and venues owned by white
men will be last in line for federal
relief
under president joe biden's restaurant's
revitalization fund
prioritizing funds for women and
minority groups as part of biden's
american rescue plan act of 2021
the small business administration is
opening the application process by which
owners of restaurants bars and other
venues
can apply for federal relief to help
make up for the loss of revenue
as a result of economic lockdowns
spurred by the chinese chronovirus
coronavirus crisis the plan allows
business owners to apply for relief of
up to 10 million dollars per business
and no more than 5 million dollars per
physical location
business owners do not have to repay the
funds so long as the money is spent by
march of 2023
the relief though is being prioritized
based on race gender and whether or not
business owners are considered
socially and economically disadvantaged
individuals
that's the report from breitbart we can
refer to the small business
administration website to confirm
breitbart's reporting
the website lays out the process and the
timeline for restaurant owners to apply
for relief
the first three weeks are designated the
priority period
kind of like priority boarding on
southwest airlines
before you get kicked off for not having
a mask on and only the priority groups
are are going to be processed and funded
during that priority period
now to discover what qualifies as a
priority group we are told to
see below and you got to scroll down a
little bit and then it clarifies that a
priority group is a small business
concern that is at least 51 percent
owned by one or more
individuals who are women or
veterans or socially and economically
disadvantaged
but who counts as socially and
economically disadvantaged once again
we're told to
see below so you do a little bit more
scrolling continuing the goose chase and
then we find this stipulation
socially disadvantaged individuals are
those who have been subjected to racial
or ethnic prejudice or cultural bias
because of their identity as a member of
a group without regard to their
individual qualities
economically disadvantaged individuals
are those socially disadvantaged
individuals whose ability to
compete in the free enterprise system
has been impaired due to diminished
capital and credit opportunities as
compared to others in the same business
area
who are not socially disadvantaged
in other words as long as you're not a
white man who never served in the armed
forces
you get to enjoy priority status white
men
can go to the back of the line how is it
fair or legal to penalize business
owners
for their race and sex and what in god's
name does any of this have to do with
covid
those are questions that you simply are
not supposed to ask there's no answer
for them that they're going to give you
anyway
the small business administration is
being straightforward in its
discrimination against men here
but they're being a bit more coy about
the racial component
so it doesn't actually say anything
about race specifically it doesn't lay
out the races that are included and not
included
it doesn't explicitly state that white
people are excluded you need to read the
subtext
but the subtext is written in big bold
blinking letters
and uh and so you really can't miss it
on the other hand
the usc the usda um is handing out its
own coveted relief
under biden's direction and that agency
is not in the slightest bit shy about
the racial bigotry embedded into the
process
here's a report from cbs it's as a group
of midwestern farmers sued the federal
government thursday alleging
they can't participate in a covet 19
loan forgiveness program because they're
white
the group of plaintiffs plaintiffs
include farmers from wisconsin
minnesota south dakota and ohio
according to the lawsuit the bite
administration's covet 19 stimulus plan
provides 4 billion
to forgive loans for socially
disadvantaged farmers
and ranchers who are black american
indian hispanic
alaskan native asian american or pacific
islander
white farmers aren't eligible amounting
to a violation
of the plaintiff's constitutional rights
the lawsuit contends
yes the lawsuit contends that but again
the agency's website confirms
these contentions an article on usda.gov
titled
faqs on american rescue plan debt relief
for socially disadvantaged borrowers
begins with this it says earlier this
week we posted important information
about the american rescue plan debt
relief payments for socially
disadvantaged producers
the american rescue plan includes
provisions for usda to pay up to 120
of loan balances as of january 1 2021
for farm service agency direct and
guaranteed farm loans and farm storage
facility loans
and then it says if you are a black
native american
alaskan native asian american or pacific
islander or are of hispanic
latino ethnicity with one of the loans
listed above
you are eligible for the loan payment
all right
so whites need not apply
they literally need not apply because
you're not going to get it because
you're white
of course the claim that all minority
farmers are socially disadvantaged
and that only minority farmers are
socially disadvantaged
is absurd on its face one of the
plaintiffs joining the lawsuit
is a man named adam faust okay
he's a disabled cattle farmer with spina
bifida
who lost one leg to a farming accident
and the other leg to diabetes
the bite administration offers him no
relief
at all on the basis that a
legless disabled diabetic farmer
has no social disadvantages because his
skin pigment
pigmentation is slightly lighter than
some other farmers
this is not only insane and grotesque
but it's out and out racism
systemic racism to be exact
because you have a powerful institution
namely the united states government
the most powerful excluding one group
based explicitly on their race
while elevating other groups based
explicitly on their race
now in our country today there are no
policies or laws
none that expressly and intentionally
elevate
white people over racial minorities you
cannot give me
one current example of that
something like this in the reverse where
you've got a government policy that says
we are here's an advantage and if you're
white you qualify it for it but if
you're not you don't
there are plenty of current examples of
of laws
that reserve special privileges for
those who are not white
but not for those who are white examples
of the reverse
and these are just two of the most
recent
so systemic racism yeah it is indeed a
problem in the united states
it's just it's not the sort of systemic
racism that the racial justice activists
want to talk about well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content